Sony Pictures and marvel studios are  proud to announce that after a full  worldwide casting search Tom Holland  will play Peter Parker also known as  spider-man in the next spider-man film  in theaters and imax and 3d on july  twenty eighth of 2017 the film will be  directed by john wats director of cop  car the upcoming thriller the made its  debut earlier this year at the Sundance  Film Festival Sony Pictures will finance  and release worldwide the next  installment of the four billion dollar  spider-man franchise and a film  co-produced by Kevin foggy and his  expert team here at marvel and Amy  Pascal who oversaw the franchise for the  studio 13 years ago together they will  collaborate on a new creative direction  for the web slinger what do you guys  think of spider-man's new star and  director tell us down below and we'll  see you next time true believers I'm  Lorraine Cink for Marvel your universe